[Music]
okay
so let's play a uh let's play another
sicilian
and we have been playing mostly the
accelerated dragon
in the speed run and this guy plays
what's called the rosso limo
bishop b5 this is kind of like the rye
lopez against the sicilian
and if you are an accelerated dragon
player thank you broken sloth it's a
good idea to play g6 here anyway
because that keeps things consistent
holy smokes sc nes all-star
now which way should we take on c6 thank
you for the five gifted mom man
girl what should we take on c6 with
so we can take with the b-pawn toward
the center but i'm actually going to
take with the d-pawn and after the game
i'll delve into the reasons for this
but basically it's a good idea to open
up our bishop and it's also a good idea
to open up the default thank you veena
blair for the prime
now we're gonna play the move e5 the
idea of this move is to clamp down on
the center
where should we get this knight
okay where should we put this knight it
blocks my bishop and
again i will explain the opening in a
lot of depth
absolutely we should get it to e7 for
two reasons first of all we don't want
to blunder the spawn second of all
we want to be able to play a five later
now our opponent plays c3
he's not actually threatening d4 one two
three
four one two three
simple counting we can absolutely go
even if he did play d4 that would not be
a problem
because it would open up our bishop our
bishop has a lot of potential energy
what do i see here yar thank you
three months at once okay so the pawn on
d3 is weak
pawn on d3 is weak how do we attack it
who can tell me the two main ways
that we can pressure that pawn there are
two main ways we see a weakness we want
to attack it the first
is the very brute force method no c4
actually he can just take gypsy thank
you
yes versus to get the bishop to a6
second
is to double up on the d file let's do
let's try to do both
q q and d prime let's go f6 never play
f6 i hear you say
it's not a problem he doesn't have any
pieces to exploit it with
right it's okay to play f6 temporarily
and now let's do the other thing queen
d7 rook fd8 is going to be our idea to
pressure
the pawn on d3 i hope everything's
making sense we're playing the 2300
so i'm playing a little bit faster than
usual because if i get into time
pressure against this guy i might land
in
in some trouble but hopefully everything
is making sense we're just trying to
attack that pawn
if we're able to win the pawn then guess
what
his position is going to collapse okay
a5 we're gonna go b5
get out of c4 now what he's accomplished
here
successfully is he has managed to block
in our bishop but
uh that's still okay thank you ryan
okay so what should we do well actually
let me think for a second guys
hmm actually this guy tricked me a
little bit here now this idea is to go
bishop e3 that's why this is annoying
his idea is to go well b4 actually might
be what we want to do here
um this pawn is weak and i didn't pay
enough attention to it so let's
think about this for a second okay
hmm
yeah we need to find a good move here
okay we're gonna go queen e6 and i'll
explain this after the game we're gonna
go queenie says by and large our idea is
to defend against queen b3 and now we
want to prepare b4
so previously the move b4 would not have
been good
because he would have had this very
nasty little check on b3 now
we are able to play b4 and we're able to
combine it with the move rook ft8
attacking why not rook 88 because the
pawn on a7 might be hanging later
and i want to make sure the rook on 8
supervises that for now okay
okay so the battle now revolves around
the pawn on d4
all right how can we go about putting
maximum pressure on that pawn
and think about it this way there's many
ways to do this
we can double rooks that's absolutely
true let's do it
we could have also gotten b3 and chased
his night away this is a very
complicated position i don't have much
time on my clock
i'm gonna have to play a little bit fast
i warned you guys about this there will
be situations
where i don't get a chance to explain
thanks to the level that i want to
explain that but right now we're going
to chase his knight away
and we're going to dig a little hole for
him here
and we're going to do that by going c4
we're going to bury his knight on a3
basically that's kind of the
rationale behind this this guy is really
really good actually really good
so i'm gonna have to accelerate the pace
a little bit
but the bottom line here is we still
want to play on the d file
and he tries to unbury his knight
another very good move
okay it's a little manga s here but
we'll be fine
no they're good these people are now
good now let's um
let's improve the position of our bishop
let's put it on a square where it's
defended by a pawn
okay he's getting his knight to a better
square
let's do the same thing let's reroute
our own knight to d6
let's reroute our own knight to d6 okay
so far everything should be making sense
we're just sort of maneuvering our
pieces to better squares
each one of us and
now let's cement our bishop with a6 i
don't want to worry about this pawn
being in a dark square so let's make it
defended
no no it's okay i i usually will be able
to talk this guy is extremely underrated
so
i'm going to have to be so now we're
going to get the bishop to a better
square
channel no 5x thank you for the gift
now what's going to be our plan our plan
is eventually going to be to pile up on
the d-pawn but before we do that
we want to make sure our pieces are on
better squares now we're going to go
knight f7
in order to open up our rook so that
they can give pressure
okay so he he decides to open that which
way should we take
who can tell me which should we take
with the knight or the pawn
we should take with the very important
not the knight actually we should take
with the pawn
the reason we shouldn't take with the
knight is because it would have weakened
the d4 square now we take the rook
and who can tell me where we put this
rook
where do we put it d7 d6 d5
all the way to d3 we put it on this
beautiful outpost
and now let's bring our bishop into the
game with bishop h6
actually that wasn't great because of
bishop e3
but you do something that wasn't great
no problem we just bring the bishop back
it's okay and now let's go h5 to
pressure his knight
okay now we're starting to really really
put the heat on him another idea to
consider would be c5
to lock out his bishop so it remains
stranded on b6
there's a lot going on trust me guys if
you can tolerate this
um i'll make this worth your while i'll
make this really instructive there's
there's a lot of concepts to unpack
um so there's a lot of concepts to
unpack here through the lens of this
game
and now i'm gonna activate the bishop
look how i'm slowly but surely i'm
pushing him off the board
and actually he just trapped my rook but
even that's fine
we can just sacrifice it
yeah this is this guy is actually like i
would say i am i
am strength easily he's i am strength
easily
okay let's go knight five i'm gonna
sacrifice the exchange that rook is
gonna be replaced with a beast of a pawn
though
and um
[Music]
okay let's go queen e6 to defend the fun
oh and i blundered this uh
i'm getting nervous myself okay let's
take
yeah we're gonna sacrifice on h3 yeah
these russians are freaking good
go back these russians are freaking
really really good okay knight h3
sacrificing the knight
if he takes it he gets checkmated
i think he maybe he knows he's playing
against my speedrun again he's bringing
his a-game
okay i'm trying to checkmate him here on
h4 my knight is restricting his queen
this guy finding all sorts of stuff
and he wants to checkmate me now oh no
that's actually not good um okay let's
get our night back
another really good move jesus
yeah he might just be beating me here
hmm it's taking a long time
now i think i'm winning because i got
this beautiful passer
look at this passer guys this is going
to win me the game
and in the end i'm going to just get my
king around and promote
this guy was really good i'm telling you
i really tried
this guy was like gm strength um
that was like a really solid game for me
actually too
jeez
no i think here he's lost because
because of h2
my apologies guys i'm sorry for not
explaining stuff at the end but let's
unpack this and that's how we'll end the
stream this will be um
and we crossed 2100 perfect
so trust me i'll make everything
understandable russians are just built
different well yeah this guy was a
just incredible okay
you want to do you want to do one more
instead of analyzing well i feel like
i feel like analyzing is going to be
important though because
i know that people like me to play but
um but analyzing trust me is
it's gonna pay off okay
so accuracy was probably low because we
were in time pressure
i wouldn't put too much stock in the
accuracy um
because because um at the end we were
both
scrambling but 80 percent
it was 79.1 and mine was 87.5 so i've
actually played really well
gemsy b5 gifted subs
yeah i know i know i was checking the
accuracy it was 79.1 to 87.5
um okay which is solid for blitz
all right so he plays the rosalina but
should be five
okay now um
the idea of this move
yeah it's like you're playing the rye
lopez against the sicilian uh it became
popular really only in the last couple
of years
it features very often at the high level
and we get
this kind of position this kind of
structure now there's good news and bad
news for black
there's good news and bad news for black
the good news for black is that i have
the two bishops
and um i have a nicely fiance bishop the
bad news is
uh you know there is a pretty big defect
in the pawn structure the reason i
didn't take bc by the way this is a
legitimate move
is um well you guys know that i like
developing the bishop on the main
diagonal now i'm gonna have to waste
another move
and also uh let's go at it from the
perspective of why dc
is good the reason dc is good is because
in a position like this and let me know
if this doesn't make sense
you guys see how big of a clamp i have
on this d4 square
this square is completely mine that
makes it very hard for him
to free his position up in the center if
we do the same thing after bc
watch what's going to happen if you go
e5
right compare this position to this
position you literally have let me
actually make the same
you know the same moves right you have
the pawn on d7 which makes it possible
for him to go d4 it's like a marotzi
bind
he goes d4 and he opens up his position
now a lot of people were thinking what
we're saying
doesn't e5 block our own bishop and i
need to come back to the point that i
always make here about
chess being like an omelette at this
level you can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs
i repeat that like a broken record all
the time
um so sometimes you need to accomplish
something in chess
and that involves making one of your
pieces bad there's also a famous saying
uh originally formulated by a romanian
brand master mihai shuba who said bad
bishops defend good pawns
and that's a very profound thing to say
because the bishop itself might look bad
but it's still like atlas holding its
worlds
holding the world on its shoulders it's
defending the pawn on e5 and the pawn on
e5 is actually
incredibly strong it's a beast so rather
than looking at the bishop as one heyman
budge as
one kind of unit think of the
bishop and the pawn as one unit think of
this as one unit
and together they're accomplishing
something great the bishop is like an
extension of the pawn or the pawn is an
extension of the bishop
thank you the real mr parent for 500
bits
thank you so much does that make sense
so that doesn't mean you have to
willy-nilly go around make all of your
pieces bad
but what it does mean is that sometimes
a piece may may be bad in the sense that
it doesn't control a lot of squares
but it may be in charge of defending
something that's important okay they're
a unit
they're a team that's why we put the
knight on e7
another 500 bits jayrud my man guys
you're spoiling me um 97 because
knight f6 would blunder the pawn and it
would interfere with my control over d4
so 97 c3 castles and
d3 so c3 was not a good move because he
weakens the square
now upon his weak we have two ways to
attack it we can simply
double on the d file or we can put the
bishop my six i actually think this was
an inaccuracy i think i should have
probably started
by doubling on the d file that might
have been a little bit simpler thank you
gm shadow for the prep my opponent found
a very good idea in response to it
which is to get the knight to c4 and
block the bishop
also something i want to point out a lot
of people confuse attacking a weakness
with getting rid of it don't play a move
like c4 because that actually helps them
get rid of the weakness
um and that's something you've got to
keep straight in your mind
when you're attacking a weakness be
careful about doing it with the pawn
because that might help him actually get
rid of it
so b6 bishop a6 knight c4
now um i played f6 in order to defend
pawn e5 but there was one thing that i
underestimated here
in addition to weakening the general
king side could somebody point out to me
in the context of this position
what is the secondary weakness of the
move f6 this this move
facilitates something that he can now do
easier and this is begins to be a
headache
so not the e6 square because he cannot
but yeah but he can't get his knight
there remember the concept of
inaccessibility
first of all it weakens the diagonal but
second of all
what idea does it make simpler to
achieve for white
remember yeah good so d4 is now
easier to achieve because the bishop is
no longer controlling that square
and that's going to be a headache in
addition it weakens the diagonal
something i also underestimated so a4
he pushes his pawn to a5 what is his
idea
he has two ideas the first after i go b5
is that my bishop is no longer attacking
the pawn the second is he's weak in the
c5 pawn which you can now pick off by
playing bishop e3 i didn't quite
you know i think i underestimated this
stuff and at this point i began to
realize
that the position gets really
complicated so if we go rook ft-8
he counter attacks this pawn with bishop
e3 and it's not easy to defend the spawn
and attack this one at the same time so
after a5
could you go rook fda yes but
um here he can play queen b3 creating
the possibility for a discovered check
and if you move the king he takes the
pawn so i think i actually kind of had
to go b5
so why did i play queen e6 at this point
i realized that if i play b4
he plays cb and as many of you have
internet what does white have
we talked about this during the game
yup that's why it's all going to go on
youtube he has the very simple move
queen b3 check now some of you might
look at this and say well that's not a
problem
right you can trade pawns but it is a
problem we were supposed to win the pawn
on d3 not exchange it also
this is just disgusting i'm not gonna
allow this i don't want to just give up
this one
so i played queen e6 in order to cover
once and for all
this diagonal and what i wanted to do
was reposition my rook on d8
the rook being the more weighty attacker
does that make sense so he goes bishop
e3
and at this point my resources are
starting to get stretched then so i go
b4 and rook fda
now the difference between this scenario
and like
this scenario is that the position is a
little bit more closed which is in my
favor
if he plays bishop takes c5 i can go
rook takes d3
and attack his queen and fork is one
this is actually good for black
um so d4 by white emphasizing
the secondary problem with the move f6
and
this is where things get super
complicated so
let's understand this position from a
broad perspective
i always like to talk about the zen of
the position or what the game is
revolving around
and that makes things easier to see what
the game is revolving around is
control of the d4 square scenario
that is good for black is i win this
pawn or i'm somehow able to put enough
pressure on the spawn to make it
collapse
the scenario that works for white is you
know he's able to get to my weak pawns
on the queen side and he's able to
retain his control over the center
which is why i double rooks that
shouldn't be a mystery to anybody
doubling rooks
increases the pressure on the d4 pawn
this should also not be a mystery to
anyone how do you decide well
it's just visually obvious right i mean
look at how many attack
look at how what everything is attacking
and defending the square there's like a
million
sources of tension one dollar thank you
mr glocks did you get my other donut um
i think i might have missed a donation
ten bucks for mr twox i'm so sorry i
missed that
uh yeah i would recommend playing 10
minutes if you're 1k thank you for the
10 bucks mr block sorry for missing that
i would say 10 min 10 minutes for now so
queen c1
why does he play this move to unpin
himself from the d file
uh if i can complete the doubling of the
rooks he can take the pawn so that's why
i go b3
his knight is the defender of the pawn
on d4 therefore
we remove uh the knight
okay yeah so for now the game is
revolving around that now
i don't want to play the move c takes d4
why
because that would open up the c file
for his queen he made a very
forward-thinking move by putting his
queen there i don't want to let his
queen
have any access to square so that that's
why i played c4 trying to bury his
knight on a3
the problem with this move is that it it
dries up the structure on the queen side
it opens up the diagonal for his bishop
after he takes and
my own bishop on a6 is now also kind of
lame yes bad bishops defend good puns
but you don't want to take that too far
so
qui outus potentially but probably not
now because that would be premature so i
double the rooks he gets his knight to a
better square
now i get my bishop to a better square
where it's at least protected by a pawn
now he makes this very ray lopez-like
maneuver getting his knight to the queen
side i get my knight to the center
and he goes king h2 which is a very
russian school of chess move he just
like improves the position of his king
he gets it away from the danger
potential danger zone
and i also make a russian move a6
reinforcing the bishop and also
the pawn on a7 is annoying me because i
could imagine a future
where he takes on e5 and he can take the
pawn on a7 if my rook ever leaves
decent hopefully this is making sense so
for rookie two
uh getting his rook to d2 he could have
played rook t1 also
and bishop f8 is how i tried to solve
uh you know it's just sort of a waiting
move well
at this point the battle has shifted
right when i play the moment i played c4
the battle has shifted from the d4 pawn
which is still a hot
hot spot but now we enter this sort of
maneuvering phase both of us
you know we sign a little cease-fire
there's no immediate threat that either
side has
so there's a mutual understanding that
both of us have to improve our pieces
before the battle heats up again does
that kind of make sense so he improves
his knight i improve
mine he gets his king to a marginally
better spot improves his rook i improve
my bishop
now i drop my knight back to f7 so that
the g5 square is covered
now here uh knight takes e5
is tempting but it would have yielded
this beautiful outpost on d4 which is
not what i wanted to do
well uh tobias chess bishop f8 bishop h6
is not a problem i can even trade
bishops and
drop my knight back to f7 with tempo i
wouldn't really mind the trade of
bishops
right so i can talk about this forever
but let's so bishop b6 i think he made a
mistake by taking he he shouldn't have
given up the defile like that and i have
now won the battle over the d
file in a certain sense right rook on d3
is beautiful and now i start improving
my pieces bishop h6
i forgot he can drop his bishop back so
we repeated moves
and instead i went h5 in order to get
his knight away from g3
and try to push him back run him out of
the gym now i go c5 in order to lock his
bishop out of b5 the bishop is in jail
at this point i think black is much
better but i made a big mistake
and he found an absolutely brilliant
idea so here i played queen d6
why get the queen to the default what is
white's idea here why did he play queen
e1
like why is this necessary and
so he wants to trade rooks the stroke on
d3 is like a bone in his throat i don't
want allowance to trade rooks i want my
rook to remain on d3
but i made a very key mistake i didn't
ask myself what he wanted
with this move knight t1 not h1 i didn't
ask myself what my opponent wanted
i simply didn't realize that knight f2
was his idea well rook d1 is strong
because the rook on d3 is strong i don't
want to get that one treated
i think i had a beautiful prophylactic
idea here to stop knight f2 and that is
the move knight g5
who sees how knight f2 is met
like how is this met the idea of knight
g5
and you should immediately see the
forkability of the knight on the rook of
the king and the queen sorry
neither of the pieces i just mentioned
were correct rook f3 he can't take the
rook because of knight takes f3 check
with the four
and uh i think this would have been the
correct move but instead i played bishop
h6 well h4 rook takes f2
the line goes on but we won't talk about
that now and i lose the exchange
and it's important not to panic in this
situation first i give a check on f4 i
wanted to soften him up with g3
so that i can then get my knight to g5
but he correctly got his king back to h1
and i decided okay uh the thing the good
thing here is that even if he takes my
rook the rook is replaced
with a pawn that is also a beast and i
can potentially support that beast by
going to c4
now why didn't i go c4 here that is a
very tempting move who can tell me
what drawback the move c4 contains
and frees the bishop bishop gets out of
jail get out of jail free card i don't
want to
get the bishop out of joe my big chance
here is the fact that the bishop is in
jail
um because that gives me the possibility
of attacking his king
with one of his pieces essentially
incarcerated the problem though is i
don't have the resources necessary
to guard the pawn on b3 and i panicked
here not really i actually found a cool
idea
but i had no choice but to let his
bishop out of jail with queen e6
now the problem is taking on d2 would
not be good because my dark skirt bishop
is my main attacker i don't want to
trade
but maybe i should have done that i
don't know when e6 my idea here
was to capture on h3 something that i
did a little bit later knight takes h3
knight takes h3 why can't he take the
knight because i played queen takes h3
now i give another check on h2 with a
bishop and regardless of where he goes
i win his queen and checkmate will
follow soon after
so knight takes h3 is a good tactical
idea this at least
at least wins back upon and now my
knight is is very nicely positioned on
an outpost
i further the outpost with 92 and now
queen f6 was a very good move
what is the purpose of this move the
purpose of this move is to tie down his
queen
to this diagonal because if he moves his
queen
he gets checkmate but he found a
beautiful way around it queen f2 is so
strong
and if i do just about anything here he
gives me a check
and then another check and he drives my
king out
and that's not going to end well so i
left the bishop out of jail
that's why i played knight d4 i need to
intercept the queen's access to a7 he
still gave me a check
i could have probably repeated moves
with a draw but i didn't want to draw
so i was able to park my king on h6
and the reason that the game isn't over
that white is not winning is because of
this pawn that is my biggest asset
and at this point i decided to trade
queens because he's threatening the very
nasty move rook v6
now most people wouldn't really do this
because we're down in exchange in an end
game but i would argue that winning this
is not simple at all
again because the pawn on d3 ties down
his knight so he can simply do nothing
and make a draw
but my opponent and time pressure
started to panic the move h4 i didn't
just make
for you know for no reason i anticipated
a future
where i would be able to eliminate this
pawn on g2 and so i preemptively
advanced my passport thank you
xa1 cap 03 and x and rook takes p5 was
very panicky he shouldn't have done that
he should have probably gone about
winning this position by coming around
to c3 and trying to snag the pawn on v3
slowly but surely
not easy but doable but in time pressure
he sacrificed back the exchange the
position remains very unclear
but now i was able to get my knight to
g2 pave the way for the pawn and he lost
on time here so
maybe white can draw by getting the king
to g1 although
it's very very close i do think black is
actually
maybe winning i don't know who's winning
maybe why is he winning i don't know
so anyway he lost on time here in a very
unclear position
very rich game you could see how many
stages this game had at first
i was out playing him then he found this
very nice idea
that introduced a lot of weaknesses in
my position the battle was revolving
around the d-bond for a while then we
locked things up
we had a maneuvering stage where we both
improved our pieces
then the position opened up again and we
had the defile stage
then he trapped my rook we had a stage
of the game where he was up in exchange
so you know so many different places
that we visited in this game
and i hope that i was able to at least
partially clarify the motivations behind
the move it was very complex i could
talk about this for
for hours uh but you know this guy
played an
unbelievably good game you know so you
can see
how the higher rated you get really this
stuff is very complicated even for me i
have to fully engage with the position
against players like these and i'm
capable of making misjudgments and
mistakes
just like any of you guys so hopefully
this gives you a certain sense of
inspiration
i you know like a move like b5 i played
mindlessly
not realizing that hey i was gonna pay
the price for this weakness it's just
that my mistakes are maybe on a more
subtle level but that doesn't mean i
don't make them and that doesn't mean uh
that i don't commit the same kinds of
hallucinations and misjudgments that any
of you guys do so you shouldn't
put anybody on a pedestal um okay
so any questions
[Music]